live local now good evening thanks for
joining us i'm denise feldes and i'm
brian loftis safety on campus top of
mind for both students and police at
unlv this after a shooting in a student
housing complex happened over the
weekend so the suspect is still wanted
by police who are working to make sure
that students feel safe especially at
night madison kimbrough is live near
campus with more
we're right across the street from the
degree the unlv housing complex where
the shooting took place it happened just
before midnight saturday night
university police and students agree
that this incident was quite the shock
i used to go to a lot of campus parties
and that's why it kind of freaked me out
a little bit shots fired late saturday
night at a house party at the degree
housing complex on maryland parkway the
person shot is expected to survive but
the suspect is still on the loose
described by police as a black man
wearing dark clothing he was last seen
on camera leaving the parking garage in
a white car while the degree has its own
security university police says they're
working with management to ensure the
safety of students so something like
this does not happen again we met with
the degree management today we're
looking at some security enhancements
maybe some video enhancements as well as
with additional patrols by my officers
in that area going forward unlv students
sharing their concerns saying this
incident puts them on high alert yet
still they remain pleased with how
campus security has been handling things
i know that the security is pretty good
on campus they drive around at least i
have late night classes because i'm in
the graduate school so i constantly see
police driving around they notify us
whenever like something happens
so
all of us got the like text message even
though we weren't like on campus
we reached out to the property manager
for the degree who said he was not able
to give out any new information
reporting live near maryland and
flamingo madison kimbrough live local
now madison thank you police are